ですから このすごいこの言葉で解釈する世界にね
引っかかって引っかかって引っかかっていますけど
何にも引っかからないようにしなくちゃいけないんです
まあそれは瞑想に関する場合は本当にここら辺が難しいんですからね
アビダンマは学生に教えるところだからね
アビダンマではまあただあのチッスカーフからあのチッタとチェータシッカ
心と心所 それからルーパ色
それから涅槃という四種類の正義体があります
世の中の人々が言っていることは全部世俗体である
言葉の世界である それは世の中の常識の立場から見れば
それそれぐらいで正しいと
仏教の教えから見れば
この四つの正義体しかないんだと
それは四つの正義体という場合も
四つの正義体と名前をつけなくちゃいけないんだと
そこでなぜ名前をつけるかというと
知るために名前をつけるんだと
ですから 知る方便 知る工夫ということでパンニャッティと言うんだと
で そこで 次にこのどのようにここ
あの このパンニャッティが生まれるかというと
いわゆるこの世俗体 言葉
どのように生まれるかというと
例えばまず耳に音が触れるとする
そこでなんとか感じるんですね
感じるだけで何も知りません
それで感じたものは まあ一応
次に聞こえたと認識するんです
それは慰問で認識するんですね
耳ではなくて だから順番があるんです
まず音が耳に触れて聴覚が生まれる
次にもう聴覚が消えるんだけど
その起きた聴覚はもう過去なんですけど
何が起きたかと 後でそれは見る
見たところで言葉入れちゃうんです
かなり後なんです だから後になればなるほど
言葉っていうのはしっかりしっかり出てきたりするんです
ですから この何ですかね
耳に起きた変化に それで意で考えて何か言葉入れちゃうんです
だから一番早く言葉を入れるんだったら聞こえただけなんです
もっと遅くなると これ鳥の声だと
車の音だとなっちゃうんです
の妄想に行ってるんです
もっと遅くなると 車の音が聞こえて
あ 田中さんだと決めたんです
例えば部屋にいると 外に車が来て
車が止まった音がすると
部屋の人はまあいろいろ判断して
車の音と止まり方 いろいろなことで
あ これは田中さんですよ
それで もう一人部屋にいる人は
なんでアンタそれ知ってますか？と
言ったら 試したところで確かに田中さんでしたとした場合はね
あんたすごいんですよと
勘が鋭くて って言っちゃうでしょうね
勘が鋭いか あんまりにも遅い
鈍いかどっちかかな だから彼がこの認識
しっかりした言葉で認識するためにたくさん時間かかってるんですね
この車の音と この前聞いた田中さんの車の音と
またくだきた似ている故に
それを車が田中さんの車と
それからまたそれで降りて
それからもう階段上がって自分の部屋に来るだろうというところまで
そういう全て過去の経験なんですね
そこでさっと判断しちゃうんですね
そこで鋭い人はそうじゃなくて
音で止まらなくちゃいけない
次に違う情報が入ってるんだから
強烈に だからこの人はいつでもボーっとしてるんです
音が聞いたらそれに沿って考えてるでしょうね
その間ではもう全くもう知らないね
世の中のこと だから結構遅いでしょうね
だからかな その勘が鋭いという人々というのは
かなり鈍くて もう嫌になるほど
そういう霊能力とかというと
ご飯が出たっても パッと食べて終わろうとはしないんですね
いろいろゆっくりと よくいられないんですね
瞑想の場合は心を訓練するためにやることとは違いますからね
神社なんかに行くと あの遅いこと
全部遅いんですね もういろいろ思って
こう言って こうやったりと
まあそこでまあどういったことはないんだけど
とにかくこの言葉がそのファンクションで生まれるんですね
で 音が耳に触れてから
触れてから慰問でそれに適切な言葉を入れるんです
というわけで もう言葉と経験の間は関係ないってことを言ってるんです
だから初めは言葉ありきと哲学を始めたら
初めからの認識ですとということになっちゃうんです
だからオームとかなんとかという音で宇宙が出来上がったんだと言ってる世界もあって
ヨーロッパでも同じことを言ってますからね
聖書でもね 初めは言葉だったんだと
それから人間がそれから出てくるんです
言葉は先にいて 人間は後から出てくるんです
人間がいて それから言葉で来たという話は言わない
仏教にすれば まず生命がいて
それから人間が出てきて
それを人間がどんどん言葉作り始めて
どんどんもうむちゃくちゃたくさん言葉ができたんだ
これからも言葉は発展していくんだっていうのは仏教の考え方で
すごい超優秀な知恵ある人々の考え方っていうのは
初めは言葉があって それから人間が出てきた
それだったら人間は成長するんだと
言葉は成長しないはずなんですけど
私たち知ってる英語でも 40年前の英語という英語っていうのはかなり違うんですね
スペリングさえも違いますよ
あの昔書いた英語の 文字も違う
あの今あの 例えばあの SH
今書くでしょうに 昔はなんか本当にこういう字があったんです
そっちの言葉で言えば何でしたっけね
あのなんか誰かが書いたあの英語のあの言語のあれね
歴史的な書いてる本なんかはね
それ全部一応サンプル出してますけども
HISTORY OF ENGLISH LANGUAGE とか何とかというね
あの これ英語をやる場合は大学ではやらなくちゃいけない一つなんですけど
それ見たら今の文字じゃないんです
使っているのは 文字もまあいくらか違う文字も使って
だから変化しているんです
例えば今 you というのは一つの言葉しかないでしょう
でも昔は you 単数と複数別々にあったんだから
例えば今は全く使わない言葉でしょう
LAD lad っていうの知ってますか？これ意味は
出ないね また LASS もあります
今意味さえわからないでしょう
昔の言葉なんです  lad っていうのは boy なんです LASS
これは last ではなくて LASS というんです
これは女と女の子なんです girl
なんです あの古い詩とかね
やると あのシェイクスピアのちょっと前のものをなんか読んだりすると出てきます lad lass
と それから damn は今知ってますね
まあコンチクショウということで damn
というこの言葉ありますけど
これはそうじゃなくて
昔はあの damn といえばご婦人という意味なんです damn damsel
ですから この私は別に今英語の授業じゃないんだけど
あの言葉っていうのは発展して変化していくんです
例えば私は昔もう変にも我々そんなにアメリカ人やらね
から英語を勉強したことがないんだけど
まあそんなお金あったわけでもなくて
そこら辺にいる先生たちから教えてもらったんだけど
こういう言葉使ってはいけませんと
間違うんだと 品がないと言われたものが
アメリカ英語になったところで堂々と使ってるんですね
オンではなくてインですよと言ったところで
アメリカ英語になったらインではなくてオンなんですね
このこういう in on at upon
とかその使い方すごい悩んでいたんです
どちらにどっちかとわからなくなっちゃって
ですから この例えばこの道路の脇
人が歩くところあるでしょ
あれは英語で何と言いますか
え？アメリカでは sidewalk なんですね
あんまりにも sidewalk なんかその通りなんですね
だからすごい一般的なんですね
今 pavement なんです
で 今使わない あれ？と思うでしょうに
その言葉を聞いたら ですから言葉は後なんです
人は先なんです だから言葉はどんどん発展していく
だから初めから言葉あって
それから人間が出てくる
というのはね まあとにかくこの言葉のあのラベリングの働きをそうやって順番で出てくる
例えば瞑想すると まず痛いんです
それで痛みとそれ確認するんですね
で 皆様のラベリングはものすごく遅すぎというところもあります
痛くて痛くて もうとにかくまずごまかそうとする
で 嫌だとも思う それでも嫌だと思ったっても
ごまかしたっても痛みですからね
まあどうしてもこの変な感覚からは逃げられない
どうしようかなと それから困ったりする
それで思い出す あ 痛みと確認するんだね
それで思い出して 痛みではなくて痛い痛いと
もう頭がおかしいんだから確認する
それで私に瞑想はしたんだけど
なかなか何も成長しているとか気がしてないんだと言うんですけど
だから私にとってはもうわかってはいるんだけど
それ言えませんだからね
ちゃんとやっちゃえばすぐ進みますよと
やってないんですね だけどやってはいけないことは全部やって
かなりの時間経ったところで痛い痛いと確認する
それ どうしようもないんですね
そういうことで だからもう一応もう何年間もじーっと待っていなくちゃいけないんですね
やらせて やらせて やらせて
やらせて そこでこの時間が自分にとってはいい
別に時間かかってない
痛みと痛みがヘタレと
それでも痛いと痛いと痛く
痛い痛いと痛い 僕は痛いじゃなくて痛み
まあどっちでもいいんじゃないかと
そこでまた思ったりするでしょうね
聞こえるんだよ こっち側には
だって痛いんだもんね
痛みとなんで？なんで痛めてみるんですか？と
だから鋭さがね 当然ないんだからね
しょうがないんだけど
だからずっと説明しなくちゃいけないんですね
痛いっていうのはやっぱり主観的で
自分の判断だと この痛みそのものではありませんと
痛みに対するあなたの感想ですよと
あなたの感想はいりませんと
事実見ましょうと 科学的な事実見ましょうと
科学者になるところで自分の好みで
言っちゃうと本物じゃないんだからね
例えばある動物の生活を研究
するんだと思って自分の好みだからといって
もうそちらのこの角を切ったり
毛がもうね 体の毛を全部カットして服を着せたりとかね
すると本当の自然の中の生き方わからないでしょう
だから だから痛い痛いではなくて
痛みで見てくださいと説明しなくちゃいけないんですね
だからこのなかなかね
だから瞑想指導というものは
この伝統的に言えば これは二
三ヶ月とか  一ヶ月とか
一年 二年间でも先生のそばにいて教えてもらいなさいというものがあったのはそういうわけだと思いますね
別にほんのちょっとなんですけど
本で書けば二ページも A四で言えばもう二ページ
三ページで終わるんですよ
瞑想のやり方っていうのは
それを一年 二年かけて覚えておきなさいと
先生とずっと一緒に生活して
というのはそういうわけなんです
そこはそれぐらい間違っちゃうんです
で とにかく言葉 経験があって
それからかなり時間をかけて
それに言葉が出てきますから
ほとんど言葉とこの経験のもう関連性ももうかなりズレてるんですね
そういうわけで 我々は人間が言葉を持ってお互いに差別を作ってケンカしたり争ったり
いろいろあるんですけど
だから鈍いほど争いが多いんですね
心が この速さっていうのは
この一秒っていうのは
このナノセカンドで考えなくちゃいけないんです
この一番早い瞬間かな
ナノセカンドといって
ね これ一秒の万分の1か百万分の1かどっちかわかってない
あまり詳しくありませんだけどね
ナノっていうのは百万分の1かな
え？十六？十五 だからナノセカンドで考えた方がいいと思いますね
だから音が触れて それもたくさん触れなきゃ気がつかないんですね
触れて 触れて 触れて それからもう時間経ったところで
もうこのナノセカンド単位ぐらいで速さで認識できたところで見えちゃうんです
この過程を だからナノセカンドっていうのは言葉だから
別に厳密にそこは存在の世界ではないんだからね
そこはそれで別に気にしなくていいんだけど
私たち知ってる一秒とはずいぶん早いことは確かに早いんです
物の変化っていうのは
そうでないと携帯電話でもうただまあ瞬時に電波行くでしょうに
それも物質的なエネルギーだから
自分の携帯電話からもう向こうのアンテナまで行って
そこでコンピューター通していろいろ変化起きて
それからまた電波発信して
またそれを相手の電話受話器まで届かないといけないんだから
すごい仕事しているでしょうに
でも私たちにとっては瞬時に送るように感じるでしょ
実は時間かかるんです
だからものの速さっていうのはすごいもんなんですね
喋ってしまって 僕は休みしようかなと思ったんだけど
でもその時間終わるまで喋ってしまったんです
今私は説明してたところのこのページで
一応こういう言葉を持って説明しています
読んでみてください で
それからこの あの一応これで終わりで ９
時まで？え？じゃあ終わりにしましょう
であの瞑想の章だからね
あの瞑想のだから瞑想の世界でも我々体験するものは決してこの実体ではありません
論理的に見なくちゃいけないんです
たとえ瞑想中 自分には神の声が聞こえても
それは神の声じゃないんです
それの信憑性は 耳で普通に聞こえる信憑性よりは少ないんです
なぜならば 長い間 何年間も瞑想したところでやっと聞こえたんだからね
事実であるならば 毎日聞こえているはずなんですね
だから科学的に見ているんです
例えば 人は玉を持って億回投げたところであるところに当たったというと
この人はぴったしそこに当たるんだと言ってはいけません
これ億回の一文だから
だからたくさんどこに当たったと見て
この人はここら辺に当たるだろうと言った方が正しいんです
それは仏教の見方なんです
他の世界の見方は逆なんですね
例えば 人が玉を持って
よく的に当たっている
投げていると それで回上げた
投げたところで 回も左の上に行ったと
また右下やらあちこち行って真ん中にも一回行った
これは 100分の1なんですね
そこで目目の球と持ったら
ちゃんと真ん中に行くというよりは左上に行くだろうという方が正しいんですね
ですから 瞑想中 何か音であろうし
あるいは他の呪文であろうか何か声が聞こえたっても
それは別に気にする必要はないんです
そこですごい光が見えても
別になんのことない幻覚です
そこでお化け見えたり
神々見えたり 鬼たち見えたりはします
いろんなもの見える 頭の中で今までのある経験やらね
そういうものから自分ご勉強したストーリーやらね
そういうものから組み立てた幻覚っていうのはね
いろんなものを見えますけど
実際性っていうのはまるっきりないんです
たとえ第戦場 仏教から言える第戦場
第戦場で現れてくる瞑想の対象についても実際性はないんです
単なる幻覚なんです ですから
なんでそんなにありがたがってありがたがっているんじゃなく
そういう幻覚のおかげで心は統一しているわけです
だから私たちが必要としたら
この統一性なんです 集中力なんです
見る幻覚はないではないんです
だから心を集中してくれるんだったら
もう何でもいいと 瞑想対象としては
この何かオームという真言密教で使っている字を使うか
あるいは禅みたいな単なる何とかの輪を描いてね
それ見るか あるいはイワシの頭を持ってきて焼いて唾をかけてそれ見てたどっちでもいいんです
集中力が生まれてくるんだったら
イワシの頭に唾かけて焼いたところで
鬼が怖くて逃げるとかね
そこはいいと 結構 あのオームという文字で仏様の大日如来の力が降りてくるんだとかね
どっちも同じ どうでもいいんです
必要なのは集中しているかないか集中できるかないか
そこで仏像は仏教の人だからね
仏像 家であった方がいいんですか？なかった方がいいんです
そんなに答えがないんです
どっちでもいいんだから
だから効果から効果の方から見るんです
仏像あったらあなたはすごく落ち着くんだったら
気持ちいいと思うならば持っていけと
ちゃんとそれを置いてもういろいろしなさいと
なくたっても本当に心を落ち着けて清らかな心でいられるんだったら
もうなくてもいいんだと
そこで仏像にしますか
マリア像にしますかと私に聞いたら
私は仏像にしなさいと言う
なぜならば その場合は
その人は何かに頼りたがってるんですね
何かに頼って心を落ち着いたがってるんですね
それだったらどう見たっても落ち着いてる
彫刻だから もう性的な欲求も生まれませんし
世俗的な気持ちも だからマリア像だったらね
子供抱いてるでしょうし
だからものすごくいろんな変なことを考えちゃうでしょうしね
ですから この 仏像にしなさいと言うかもしれません
そう言われたんだからって
仏像に特別な不可思議な力あるんだとかだとか
それはよしなさいということね
いつでもそうやってかなりの合理性があって
物事を見なくちゃいけないんです
だからそこですごい柔軟性なんです
自由なんです 全然この合理性でもって人がすごく頑固になるかというと
そうじゃないんです 合理性でもって
仏教ではものすごく柔軟になっちゃうんです
だからそこで世俗的な合理性と仏教の合理性の違うところなんです
お数を使うか使わないかとかね
我々はすごくそこで柔軟なんですね
ある日蓮系の人が私に電車でずっと 30 分間ものすごい説教したんですね
自分が持っている数こそ正しくて
本物の数だと なぜならば
そこは宇宙の大宇宙の形がそこにあるんだと
またかえって人間の形もそこでできて
そこを念々法蓮華経と念じることによって
宇宙の力 よく説明したんですからね
だからって私は別になんであの実は丸い輪でなくて
なんか変なもの 2つぶら下がってるんですね
また小さな 2つ また上にもあるんですね
なんでこいつらがこの変なお数持ってますか？ということがわからなかったんですね
そこを説明聞いたところ
なるほど これは足で これは頭だと
これは体だと そういうふうに思ってるんだと
それで私にとっては それは私の理解であって
それで終わっちゃったんですね
あの人響いた説明は単なるゴミであって
何の意味もないんですね
ですから これは昔のお坊さんとはお互いに誰がかっこいいか
誰がかっこいいかとね
ものすごい低次元的なことで喧嘩しているでしょうね
だから衣の色やら着け方やら
心に輪っか入れるか入れないかとかね
紫色にするか赤色にするかとかね
金糸でやるか あるいは普通のシルクの糸で
置いたりするかとか そんなもんの世界だから
ジュースにしたっても
そのその坊さんが自分なりのまあバージョンですか
を作るんでしょうし 別にそこはそれでいいんです
遊びだからね それで後の人々が単なるこの輪っかみたいなジュースがなんとなくちょっと物足りなくなったかもしれませんね
中国に来たところで仏教が
それでもうちょっとぶら下がっていた方が今日本の皆持ってるジュースもそうでしょ
何か尻尾みたいな馬の尻みたいなものあるんだからね
だからそれはもうおしゃれであって
それでいいんじゃないんですかね
それではいいんで 今若い人々いますよ
見たらもうジュースちゃんとついてるんです
あれは宗教心じゃなくて
ただのおしゃれなんです
何かのブレスレットよりはジュースの方がいいと
だから私から見てもおしゃれするんだったらその方がいいと思ってるんです
聞いたら ご自身に聞いたら
金のあーだこうだとかブレスレット作るよりは普通の日本で売ってるおジュースを掛けていた方が
なぜならばまず落ち着きがある
派手ではないし いいんじゃないかと
そういうことで この論理的にっていうのは
まあ本当にすごい柔軟性ある
このガリガリ人間になることじゃないんです
理解するんです 人々やること
そこでこのどこまで意味があるか
どこから意味がないかという
どっちでも理解する そういう世界なんですね
じゃあまた次の瞑想の方に入りますので
できるだけ早く終わりにしようという努力はあります
だから時々注意してくれるんだったら早くしてくださいと
私は早くします あ ごめんなさい
[物音]